Bailey: I was attracted to the WHIP program
before even applying to Hillsdale itself.
I first decided to apply to the college, the
whole knowing that they have this fabulous
program that allows you to live, work, and
study in Washington D.C. I can't stay in a
classroom forever. It's my responsibility
to go out and use my education, so this is
a wonderful bridge to go out and apply what
I've learned at Hillsdale.
My favorite part about this internship program
is that it forces you to balance. It challenges
you right from the start. You have to learn
how you're going to get enough sleep every
night so that you can show up and be a responsible
intern, listening to your supervisors, excelling
at your tasks; but then at night, making sure
that you're prepared for classes and that
you're ready to engage and talk about the
readings and ask questions.
Whenever I have the opportunity to speak to
someone who's interested in the program but
hesitant about spending the time here in D.C.
away from campus, I remind them that, yes,
your Hillsdale experience is valuable. You
may only get four years on the campus or less.
You have to remember that Hillsdale is not
confined to the campus. That experience extends further.